I don't like that butter you would do
this who made somebody talk to them so
that's a no on the pimple I don't know
but then I keep going back in
[Music]
so much I never heard about the poppet
pal I thought why did this product even
exist and we're gonna get one I need to
know what this is about the poppet pal
seems like a way to get that
satisfaction of popping a pimple without
dirtying up your pores my boyfriend gets
a lot of blackheads I squeeze the
blackheads out of his face and he's like
that's disgusting I find it really
satisfying to pop a pimple it's like a
little bit of it feels like I
accomplished something I love picking
pimples
I still watch videos of Sandra Lee dr.
pimple popper I watched to help me fall
asleep I actually can't watch pimple
popping videos it freaks me out
after I stopped wanting to throw up I
was like come on Sandra get it out get
it out so satisfying watching pimple
popping is very soothing it's just like
ah so good it looks kind of like spam
that's been like left out oh it just
feels like plastic like a little slimy
this is very scientific squeeze with two
fingers to pop the pimple and have fun
and you can refill it so you can do it
over and over again I'm about to pop my
first pimple oh it's coming uh
this is a good one look at all my nail
it's not the same but it is satisfying
I'm a little grossed out yeah but the
pus is very satisfied we're gonna be
taking these home and we're gonna see if
it's as good as popping a real pimple
hopefully it'll help me keep my fingers
off my face
meant for adults this is hard this pill
popper and I have quite the weekend I
introduced it to my girlfriend you need
to pop a pimple
she equally hated it and loved it oh no
I keep doing it she was visibly and
verbally hating on it but she also
couldn't stop popping it oh that was a
good one walking around the office and
they were like hey what's that in your
hand oh my gosh so much it's gross but
amazing at the same time why do you buy
one yes so that was my boss and she was
obsessed with my friends and I was like
you got fries and stuff I'm gonna show
my friend Caitlin here I had her like
close her eyes and everything she was
like what is this she was like is this a
bar of soap and I'm like it's it's kind
of like the opposite she like loves
popping pimples and she like fell in
love with it everybody in the bar was
like looking at us they're like what are
they playing with it's like a stress
outlet for me and being able to pop
those just literally brought lights my
life my roommates were also interested
in it they weren't as disgusted one of
my roommates actually put the puss on
her lips to leave moisturize alright I
found out that it works really well it's
a lip balm I was really surprised my
roommate Mitch liked it a lot this mitch
is a very pretty boy likes to take very
good care of himself so seeing him play
with the pimple popper is kind of funny
when I got home my boyfriend who is a
medical student is studying I told him I
had surprise for him something I'm gonna
like maybe so I handed it to him and
your nose pimple videos I like watching
this lets you pretend to pop pimples
however anyone want to do
Oh Oh jumps out of you oh no [ __ ]
gross yeah he like hates it when I like
pop his it but when we were doing it
together he was explaining to me all the
medical terminology follicular
hyperproliferation
inflammation the presence of excessive
sebum production I buy everything
travel-size oh my god it's so cute I
could bring this with me everywhere
whatever who cares what people think I
think I'm gonna pop some pimples on the
High Line guys there's like nothing
better than just popping a couple
pimples while having view New York City
this totally relieved my stress class
kept coming and coming and coming out of
them I think I'm starting to like kind
of like it but it doesn't fight back
like a pitbull we had like a little
adventure because we wanted to refill it
place pitbull pus and microwave for 10
seconds we don't we don't have a mic
like it's fun to pop but then I get
anxious because I know I have to refill
it again refilling it it just was like
disastrous like I cut a hole at the top
of this to try to get like the puss in
this crack resorted to just like pushing
it inside each little hole so it starts
to make me forget like cringe a little
bit I just see like all these like
little like gouges I don't even want to
pick my own pimples I didn't wear it
because I just think of this the pimple
popper didn't really work for me it
actually may have made my pimple popping
activities worse don't you do it you're
supposed to use this
you know that doesn't get rid of my
actual talking about it so much made me
look at my face and like see how many
pimples I actually have do you see those
I think my boyfriend was glad that I was
popping this instead of his face gonna
poke some temples go play with your
puppet like not my face why not
it was gross that kind of distracted me
from the blackheads in his forehead the
best thing the pimple popper brought me
was new friends on the subway so just
popping during my commute because I
wanted to like chill out and these guys
just came up to me and they're just like
what are you doing normally you don't
talk to anyone
on the train everyone's trying to be
test so it was cool to like have this
small conversation with people over
something silly and kind of gross we
started talking about pimple popper
videos and they're like oh I love those
I'm like gross but I'm the one fake
popping pimples on the train so I
learned that it's just like a really
polarizing a subject for someone that
has that kind of obsession with like
wanting to like pop stuff this is a
better alternative because you're not
gonna hurt your skin everybody who
popped pimples should try this product
because it really changes the way that
you feel about pimple popping
being this up and close with it maybe
really think about how I should be
treating my own skin I would give it 5
out of 5 if this little eyedropper work
better it's going to get a reaction out
of people whether they like it or hate
it I don't think that we should be
disgusted by Ireland biology everyone
gets it and we should celebrate that
instead of shutting it I'm surprised
that this hasn't been on Shark Tank yet
honestly because I think up is a huge
market for it
it's like my little [ __ ] baby